all right let's do Friday feedback or
the Feed Bag Friday or you know you all
know what it is all right let's get
right into it Steve wrote in Steve had
some unkind words to say about the show
as if someone is forcing him to watch
Steve writes you are one uninformed
uneducated POS stupid mother effer Trump
will win be quays people know how effing
corrupt and treasonous the left-wing
lunatics and the media like you ftard
really is I think you mean really are
Steve I think you mean really are
um yeah you know it's interesting it's
either they call you uneducated or they
say well you're educated but the
education is a liberal
indoctrination which is it Steve please
tell me exactly which one of the two it
is now on Trump will win
remember these are the same people who
were insisting Trump will win in 2020
and then Trump lost and now they go well
he actually did win so they're not
exactly folks who who will revise their
claims or predictions if it were not to
come to pass just an important thing to
keep in mind there's no way to have a
good faith discussion with folks like
that uh trist oh there were people who
came so this this always happens during
election season
I will live stream an event
and the event might be a Donald Trump
event like I streamed the Trump CPAC
speech and people are just looking for
the speech they don't know who I am they
find my stream and they watch and they
see that some of my commentary is less
than glowing about Donald Trump and then
they write to me one such person is
Tristan who wrote To Me and said
oh no this is not an example of that
we'll get to that this is actually a
different type of email okay Tristan
wrote to me and said dear David watching
your live stream of Donald Trump's rally
what is shocking to me is that I am
excited by the entertainment value
of trump being back on Center Stage I
could not hate him more but it's
fascinating how the hatred of him is
entertaining Tristan
I heard from a bunch of people on the
left about this saying to me David you
know
I really couldn't think Trump was any
worse for the world it's it's a disaster
his ideas are terrible his lack of
decorum the way he is debased politics
it's all horrible
but it's so damn funny to watch him give
these speeches where he glitches and
gets confused and says insane things and
it's just it's like a disaster porn of
sorts here's my take on that
I would say that as long as you're
voting and you're working to improve the
situation in the United States
I don't think that you're doing
something wrong by being entertained by
the insanity assuming you never lose
sight of the reality that left unchecked
meaning if Trump becomes president it's
really really bad for the world in the
country as long as that context is there
there is an entertaining layer to the
insanity of trump that's sort of where I
would leave it from the subreddit user
bug operator wrote have voter fraud
conspiracy theorists ever offered a
reason as to why voting machine
companies wanted Trump to lose I mean
motive is one of the three main elements
of a crime yet I've never actually heard
anyone accusing dominion and smartmatic
of fraud explain why they would have
wanted to rig the election for Biden
what could they possibly have had to
gain by doing this I highly doubt
they're just anarchists who wanted to
create chaos for the hell of it so
what's the actual reason behind the
conspiracy I know it's asking a lot to
assume these people even have a reason
but I'm curious if anything even
remotely resembling a motive has ever
been put forth so what I've it's a
really good question which is if you're
smartmatic or your Dominion voting
systems why would you have a preference
for one candidate over another your if
profit is your motive your preference
would be that your machines are used
more and more
and so doing something that risks
exposing you in some way or what none of
it makes any sense the best claim I've
seen made from the people who believe
this nonsense is that the voting machine
companies are owned by or controlled by
democrats so that the the companies
themselves are a tool
for Democrats to win elections that's
the best thing I've heard and obviously
there's no evidence that that took place
um okay
I spoke last week about how it would be
a good thing for us to have more
non-lawyers as presidents of the United
States and in general in politics and
Houdini did it commented on YouTube the
biggest issue with non-lawyers is that
our government is about law from Obama
to Raskin to Bernie to Jeffries having
depth and understanding of law makes all
the difference on the floor and in
debates just look at how Marjorie Taylor
green and bobert or Beau bear are
constantly torn to shreds we don't need
the Democratic equivalent
um that is interesting now I have to
look something up is Bernie a lawyer I I
think I actually don't know that about
Bernie education Brooklyn College
University of Chicago bachelor's degree
um yeah so burnt Bernie's not a lawyer
that that what's interesting about this
is the argument that's being made here
which is
these lawyers are better is that this
this person is listening Bernie who is
not a lawyer
so if anything it seems to me to prove
that it would be fine and a good thing
to have more non-lawyers now I am not so
naive that I believe
every uh field every career makes one
well set up to be an elected official or
president of the United States I'm not
arguing that what I am arguing is that
we don't have nearly enough uh a broad
representation of career types
um in government and I would like to see
that uh changed s strange commented when
I borrowed my brother-in-law's Maga hat
back in 2016 I pointed out the made in
China tag and the irony his response and
I'm not kidding was that just means
Trump is smart he makes more money that
way I shook my head in disbelief well
shaking's one head in disbelief is a
common and reasonable reaction
um too much of what these hypocritical
right-wingers do and this little uh
exchange that this person is recounting
is emblematic of why I'm increasingly
convinced that as a wholesale strategy
for winning elections convincing people
like this simply isn't going to work and
the reason is as as is pointed out here
they come up with some initial statement
well listen we gotta stop with the made
in China stuff we've got to bring back
our make stuff domestically and bring
back the supply chains and all of this
oh okay well the guy who you follow is
manufacturing stuff in China that oh
well that he's smarter for doing that
I'm sure he pays less money
you are not going to be able to win
these people over by exposing the double
standard in hypocrisy of the failure to
adhere to principles you're not going to
and so as a personal thing if you enjoy
trying to change the minds of people
like this by all means have at it I have
said before and I will say again I don't
think that it will help us win elections
because I don't know at the wholesale
level how you deal with that dog Hollow
weighed in about Mitt Romney
and says we're at a point where Mitt
Romney has become a voice of reason in
the Republican party I have to admit
I've grown to respect him I remember
when he was in big trouble for putting
his dog kennel on top of his car and
just a bad choice now I would have given
anything for him to be president instead
of trump everything is relative yeah I
think that the reason this is uh well
said is oftentimes when I'll mention
something about even George Bush
wouldn't or Mitt Romney this or that
I'll get some messages from people
saying oh you're like glorifying these
people you're rehabilitating them no no
no no it's not that I'm rehabilitating
them I still see them as I did before
it's just that compared to trumpism they
aren't as bad
right and so when we think about Mitt
Romney yeah Mitt Romney as a Mormon is a
social conservative and has views I
don't agree with but the guy marched
with black lives matter he has gone
after a lot of these hate movements from
the right would I disagree with Mitt
Romney about tax policy of course would
Mitt Romney likely try to cut Social
programs that I would like to expand
rather than cut yes but their
differences of a different category to a
great degree uh than much of what we are
seeing with trumpism which is just
unhinged insanity
um a user from our subreddit asks is
David playing Billiards on the new set
last couple of days there has been a
noise in the background of the podcast
that sounds like a pool like a pool
table is David running a pool hall out
of his new studio are there dart boards
is it possible someone is running a
lathe you have you know when you when
you build a new studio
which we did
there are often little things that don't
go quite right I'll give you an example
with my chair see I'm in a chair I'm not
standing during the show with the chair
that I use
where I re it has adjustable armrests
where I really want the arm rests I just
put it is a little bit higher than where
I have them set but the problem is
there's a glitch with the left arm rest
button where if I put too much weight on
it okay
it goes down one click and so honestly I
don't even know how it keeps getting up
to that top top setting but what
sometimes will happen is that it will be
set there and I'll shift my weight and
then it'll make a Gunk okay of sorts the
other issue is that as a result of the
arm rests not being where I want them
there's an issue where they make contact
with the desk and sometimes
there will be another noise we're
working on every one of these things
believe me they bother me as much as or
more than they bother you but there are
no Billiards being played we're not
running any power tools here
um nor are we uh nor are there dart
boards or anything like that but I I do
appreciate the concern all right you can
email info davidpackman.com if you have
something to say for Friday feedback
sometimes we'll take a YouTube comment
sometimes we'll take a Twitter reply or
a Facebook message or whatever the case
may be just remember if you interact
with the show what you say may become
part of the show with identifying
information of course respectfully
removed we have a fantastic bonus show
today Pat's out this week so you'll have
me for the Friday bonus show much to the
pleasure or dismay of different people
in the audience depending on your
preference sign up at joinpakman.com
I'll see you then